nuclear terrorism is how iran has
described
this latest incident at its main
enrichment facility
pointing the finger at israel
what happened in the tons as israel's
officials have said it several times
and what we are hearing from different
sources it confirms that
israel was behind this incident u.s
media said it was an explosive device
and not a cyber attack
although they quoted unidentified
intelligence sources
there's still very little information
out of iran about how the attack was
carried out
in my view without a doubt this is
definitely not a coincidence
and one thing you need to remember while
it is uh
israel is the usual suspect in these
events
over the last few years one must be
mindful there there are many opponents
in many different corners
to the resumption of the joint
comprehensive plan of action
not the least of which is from within
iran itself
iran is now urging the international
atomic energy agency to take action
saying it reserves the right to punish
the perpetrators
this development comes at an important
time as iran prepares to return to
vienna for talks
negotiations about the 2015 nuclear
agreement
started last week with indirect talks
between tehran and the united states
president joe biden says he's willing to
rescue the deal that was abandoned three
years ago by his predecessor donald
trump
that is if iran comes into compliance
with the deal
there's now been two attacks against the
nation's nuclear facility in the space
of a year
and israel has also been blamed for the
assassination of iran's league nuclear
scientist
and last week's attack against an
iranian ship in the red sea
this latest incident has yet again
raised questions about the country's
ability
to protect its facilities iran has
always bolstered about its nuclear
achievements and capabilities
leverage it wants to use in negotiations
just days ago state television aired a
music video promoting its nuclear
program
but for now it's unclear how much damage
has been inflicted
and how far back the program has been
set aside beg
al-jazeera tehran